I mean there's there's this uh you know
misunderstanding about Libertarians and
anarcho capitalists that like we don't
want you know we don't believe in the
state so we don't want to see criminals
putting behind bars like couldn't be
further from the truth like you can't
speak for all Libertarians they get
pissed off when you do that kind of
stuff well I'm going to do it anyways uh
don't really care they can get mad at me
uh yeah I think if there's one group of
people that all Libertarians agree ought
to be behind bars it's corrupt
politicians that are ruling over us
against our will you know from Jump
Street well Phil would you agree uh I'm
not a Libertarian but uh no but from
your perspective in your opinion you
said people don't like talking for
Libertarians but you think Libertarians
want to see the corrupt politicians
locked up I think that there is there is
the most uh if there is a role for the
state then policing corruption is
probably among the the most fundamental
things that the state should have to do
I mean you don't want a state that's
that's passing a lot of laws anyways